it really means a lot to me when i can
finally get to a place where
i share who i really am and i've been
like
really insecure for a long time and i'm
finally like at that place where
i have self-confidence i'm not gonna cry
and i'm really happy that i get to share
that with you all chloe bailey got
emotional on
instagram sunday talking about her
journey to self-love
after haters shamed her recent instagram
posts
including chloe doing the busset
challenge
and this clip at home saging her room
in her underwear
[Music]
so chloe hopped on instagram live to
address the criticism
head on for every woman out there don't
change who you are to make society feel
comfortable
and i'm telling myself that's not what
i'm going to do
and even when i posted the video
yesterday i was posting it because i was
saging and doing
polysanto and i was like let's spread
positive vibes i didn't even really
notice you all would talk about my ass
because i'm like okay i'm just walking
in for one second two seconds
you know and i feel like i've shown my
ass more than i have with that like if
you look at our performance videos the
last performance we had
in december like i was just so excited
and on stage and just being myself
and the grownish star held back tears as
she talked about learning to love
herself
something she says hasn't been easy i
think it's so
important and so special when a black
woman
can be strong and stand in her power in
every single way
you know i do it musically with my
songwriting with my producing i feel so
badass
and i get the same feeling when i dance
in my room
when i just own who i am and my body
and for so long i used to think i was
like fat
and like i used to hate my stretch marks
and my cellulite
i'm not gonna cry
but it's like now i really love who i am
and at the end of the day
she says she just wants people to know
the real chloe
if you don't believe in yourself no one
else will i just felt it was important
to address it so you guys get to kind of
get to know who i am more inside
and it's really hard for me to think of
myself as a
sexual being or an attractive being
quite frankly
so when i see all the uproar about my
posts and stuff i'm a bit confused like
i really don't understand because
i've never seen myself in that way back
in 2018
chloe opened up to et about having a
tender heart
during a visit to the set of her hit
freeform series
i'm very sensitive i only let it show in
front of people i'm comfortable with
and we like to be like never let them
see you sweat so if you're around
people who you don't want to see you cry
just go in the bathroom
i go to the bathroom and in 2020
shortly after the world went into
lockdown due to the global pandemic
she told et she was using the time off
to do a little self-care
yeah i don't think people need to feel
pressured to like
become their best selves in this moment
it's okay to take the pause and
you know self-reflect and it's and even
if you are
it's really creative that's great too
you know yeah
you